okay i'm sorry oh you're not gonna be
able to see the titles but i will give
you
information on what's going on
so what i've started to do during my
postdoc and now as a staff scientist is
really to understand and increase our
focus on what we actually care about so
when you look at an environmental sample
you do want to know everything's there
everything that is there we want to know
what they're doing this is your genetic
repertoire you want to know all the
capabilities of what's going on
but we also care at each point in time
who's actually doing what
and the more we study microbes and other
organisms and how they interact the more
we understand that not everything's
active at a single time point that
actually in soils a majority of
microorganisms are inactive
they can be active they can be growing
but a lot of them also dormant or
they're just deceased and we're picking
up what's called this relic or ancient
dna from the soil environments
so to get around this we use stable
isotope probing as one way
so this is where we take an isotope and
this first example i'm going to tell you
it's going to be for
for oxygen so we have regular water
which is typically
h216o
but we can make what's called heavy
water which is
h218o not to confuse with deuterium
we're specifically using 18o
so when we add this to an environment
like soil
water is a universal substrate so
anything that's active
is going to have to use this water so it
becomes labeled with the 18-0 within its
dna so we can detect everything that's
active now for viruses if they're
infecting a host
then they will also get labeled so the
viruses get labeled as well
in another example
i'm going to show you how we can look at
substrate specificity so here you have
plant biomass which usually has
normal carbon which is 12c
we can grow plant biomass with under 13
co2 so it's in rich plant biomass so the
majority or all of the plant is 13c
enriched we can then look at who's
degrading that plant biomass because any
organisms that are breaking down will
become 13c and rich and so will their
viruses so this won't label all active
organisms and biological entities this
will only label the ones that are
involved in breaking down the plant
biomass so it's substrate specific
so what we typically do from this is we
incubate the sample this will be soil
for a period of time then we extract all
the dna like you would from metagenome
but then we take the dna and we put it
on a cesium chloride density gradient
and we do ultrasonification
the dna will separate into the different
layers of cesium chloride density based
on enrichment
so you'll have dormant or ceased ones
that didn't intake didn't take up the
180 or didn't take of the 13c up higher
in the lighter fractions the ones
incorporated the heavier isotope that's
more dense will be in the denser
fractions and we can physically separate
these and sequence in them separately
and compare them now there are
differences in this obviously there's
organisms that are gc rich that can make
them more dense so we end up taking many
fractions and comparing those fractions
but it's important always sequence both
the light and the heavy fractions this
allows us to get the genetic repertoire
of everything that's going on remember
we took a snapshot in time so it could
be that the metabolisms that weren't
active had just stopped right before we
added it for some reason so this is
where time series also comes in handy
but then also allows us a control to
compare it to to see differences in
growth and changes in the communities
so the first example i'm going to talk
about is with the heavy water and this
is a paper i recently published i think
came out in august of last year
and this is where we went to bonanza
creek and alaska in a zone that has
permafrost which is ground that's frozen
for two or more consecutive years
now the assumption is in these northern
latitudes siberia
scandinavia
canada alaska
that over the winter organisms just
don't function
and be or it's minimum so they just
ignore a lot of the carbon that leaves
these soils and they don't want to
measure it but we've known for quite
some time that this is false so we
wanted to actually
connect microbes and viruses to carbon
cycling over winter months
so we sampled bonanza creek
and we collected the peat soils
and then we took the soil we incubated
in a jar for a half a year and for full
year and we did some of the samples with
regular water and then some with
enriched water
and then we also brought the temperature
of the vials down slowly over time to
negative 1.5 celsius and we also made
sure they're in axe anoxic with a
nitrogen head space
so this will mimic the in-situ winter
conditions
after the incubation we then did the
cesium chloride density fractions and we
secrete them separately and we
reconstructed 23 metagenomes
along with this we were collecting
headspace measurements so we can measure
co2 production over time so in the
figure at the bottom you can see in
purple from our samples that we had co2
production that occurred over the full
year incubation
we also saw on our other control which
we brought down the negative 20 that
there was no production so somewhere in
between there we have our limits of life
being able to
respire
so i'm going to just do some quick
highlights but the main things i wanted
to focus is on the viruses here
so i have a heat map here on the x-axis
we found 332 viral populations
on the y-axis i have a four different
treatments we have regular water for a
half a year in rich water for a half
year and then both for a full year and i
compared them
so if we look at just the bottom part
that's our active ones so we found that
243 of our 342 populations were active
over the winter so it's incredible as
the large amount of viruses active in
the winter
we're looking at just the active ones
now we first noticed comparing a half
year to a full year that many of the
viral populations persisted so if you
look from the happier full year they're
still there so that's the first thing to
note
the second thing is that a large portion
of them actually increase their
abundance over time so it's not like
they were active and then they just sat
there they continue to infect or
multiply in the host over the rest of
the year
and some theories on what could have
happened is that these could have been
tempered viruses that were integrated in
the host and as the host
doubled the virus also doubled it could
be that they burst out of their hosts
and made virions and the virons
persisted in the environment and we do
get a little bit of this and our
metagenomes but it's not targeted like a
viral so we don't get a lot of virions
it also could be that these viruses and
maybe the hosts died and exploded and
because these are p-lens soils and their
soils the
dna is protected so it could be that
they just remain as relic dna in the
environment
i also want to highlight to left you can
see we had viruses eight viral
populations that were present at half a
year and were no longer present after a
full year so we're seeing this dynamic
community in which populations are
leaving and populations are coming into
play
and that brings us into the 151 new
populations that just occurred from a
half year to a full year
and not discuss too much more about it
but if you look at the host it seems
like the viruses are mimicking the host
that when the host populations are
changing the viral populations are
changing too following the kill the
winner hypothesis
to talk about the host a little bit we
had this huge diversity
where we had 10 bacterial phyla
in these subfreezing anoxic soils which
is incredible in itself
but we also saw that seven of that
tenfyla were active so we had bacteria
that are active over winter so that
means they're doing something
and if you were to take a traditional
metagenome you would have sampled all of
these and you would have seen that there
was 10 bacterophylla you would have also
specifically focused on actinobacteria
because if you look at general reed
information and coverage the
actinobacteria dominated the signal but
this just occluded the actual truth of
what was going on
when we actually looked at the active
organisms
we saw that latino bacteria were not
even that active that the majority of
them were actually firm acutes and
bacteriodes so we would have missed this
signal had we not done the stable
isotope probing metagenome
of those seven only four actually had
viruses in which we detected were
infecting the host and then they changed
throughout the year as well
so i wanted to highlight that we had the
the patsy bacteria these are incredible
because these are ultra small bacteria
part of the candida phylum radiation
which is newly discovered so these
organisms are interesting because they
don't really have a free living system
they have to connect with other hosts so
they typically can connect with bacteria
dd's or antenna bacteria so there may be
some syntrophic relationship with
viruses infecting multiple hosts
we also found our proteobacteria
specifically these vampiric bacteria
which these are
bacteria that have to attach to other
bacteria and feed on them to survive and
we found viruses infecting these
bacteria and then again as i said before
the firmicutes and the bacterias were
the most abundant phyla and these are
the ones the viruses switched to infect
throughout the year
okay
just to sum it up i'm happy to talk more
if people want to know more about the
paper but some key takeaways there's
major differences between the active and
the unlabeled communities so there is
promise and trying to decrease our
complexity and look at the active
portion only
we found only a few bacterial
populations are active but we found a
ton of viral populations that were
active
when we looked more to the host
abilities they had the ability for
fermentation and to also break down
carbon and they produced co2 throughout
the whole sample so this is important
because this showed and links bacteria
to producing carbon dioxide over winter
processes so we need to be thinking
about co2 loss over the winter
especially because of some studies out
there that suggest that co2 loss over
the winter is actually more than the
entire plant uptake during the growing
season
so we had one third of our viruses were
linked to active hosts we may be able to
increase this if we were able to do a
viral targeted metagenome also known as
a virum
we also found that viruses included
these key genes to modulate the host
metabolism so these are known as
auxiliary metabolic genes these are
genes that are outside the viruses
normal repertoire to infect the host and
sometimes can bring genetic novelty to
the host or can modulate the host
metabolism in this case they help the
host of carbon degradation and also
scavenging nutrients from the
environment probably aiding in survival
and then i think it's important to note
that the viral community did shift from
who they infected from a half year to a
full year which was supporting the kill
the one or hypotheses showing that the
viral communities do shift to who the
most abundant host is
okay so for our next experiment this is
going into our 13c enriched plant
biomass we're now shifting gears getting
out of that frigid cold arctic
environment we're now in the lush
tropical rainforest in puerto rico the
lukiyo experimental forest
so this is
puerto rico's part of the united states
and this is the only tropical rain
forest that is part of the united states
so we sampled there and what's important
to know about these environments is they
have tropical storms so it's a it's a
common occurrence for there to be heavy
rainfalls and dry periods so these soils
undergo heavy redox conditions where it
can be anoxic and then oxic and we're
wondering how this affects the fate of
the carbon and how what tools have the
and traits of the microbes picked up to
survive and what are the viruses doing
so this experiment was designed by
ashley campbell and managed by our group
leader jennifer pettridge the far right
and then i had jeff kimbrell and steve
blazewitz that helped me as well
and they designed this experiment where
they took soil samples
and for 44 days they incubated them
under four different treatments
and they added the 20 grams of the soil
with the plant biomass and i just want
to remind you that this is not labeling
all active organisms so we're
specifically looking at ones involved in
degrading or breaking down the plant
biomass
so the treatment setup was it was either
completely oxidic with air being flushed
in it was frequency between oxygen
anoxic at a high amount or a low amount
or we had ones that were completely
anoxic with an n2 headspace
from this we are able to take 95
metagenomes so this is huge we had
terabytes of data
now we wanted to really compare and ask
the question
when we do the sip fractionation
and we're looking at the active ones are
we actually decreasing the complexity
enough to actually get increased
resolution so we took 85 step fraction
and metagenomes this is where you
extract the dna and then we do the
different fractions to see which ones
are heavy and light and then we compare
them and then we have 10 bulk soil
metagenomes this is just we took some
soil we extracted dna and we sequenced
it so this is your traditional
metagenome and we wanted to compare them
okay i have a heat map here again and
let me orient you to how it works on the
x-axis we have our viral populations you
can see already we had double the amount
of viral populations compared to our
arctic samples
now for the color scheme
an orange means whitening is not present
orange means low abundance green means
high abundance and then the y axis i
have it separated from in black are bulk
meta genomes with our different
treatments
in blue we have our no addition this is
just plant biomass so it's our control
and then in red at the bottom we have
our 13c enriched plant biomass that we
added to compare and you can see we see
viruses in all the samples and there are
some changes
so now we're going to dig more into
those active ones the ones involved in
carbon degradation
so looking at this the first thing you
should notice is that there's more viral
populations in the oxic samples so we've
known for quite some time that auction
really affects viruses and it makes
sense when a virus is infecting a host
if it's lytic it wants to take over the
host and make progeny viruses
this is oxygenic metabolism that you
need so we see about a third of our
viral populations were here
and then you see some changes when we
have redox conditions
but what is super cool
sorry so we have about a third that are
in all the conditions
um but what's important to note
is that in the oxic ones we have 27
more viral populations so you think
oxygen is important but then if you look
at the anoxic one while we have less
diversity
the virus the viral populations that are
there
are the most abundant
so here i'm thinking we have some
viruses
that you know they probably don't have a
broad host range they probably don't
have these large genomes these are
specialists
they've changed the way they infect to
change the host metabolism where now we
have this anoxic metabolism completely
different pathways and viruses evolved
to work with this and we don't have
these oxygenated viruses here so this is
a niche spot
just for these viruses and this story's
not published yet so i'm still actively
looking into
what these viruses are doing because
this has important implications for us
right we have parts of our body that are
oxygenated and we have parts of our body
that's anoxic so our microbiome
including our viruses are going to
change in those different redox
conditions
okay so then just to highlight the host
real quick we had massive diversity i
mean these are tropical rainforest soils
this is something you would expect we
had 20 phyla of bacteria
detected
and in here in this figure f here of
alluvial chart
on the first column we have all of our
viruses in the middle i was trying to
get an understanding of connecting
viruses to the host amongst the
different redox treatments
and then the far right column we have a
different phyla bacterium the main
takeaway i want you to get from here is
that we have huge diversity and if you
kind of follow the green which are the
viruses that were 13c labeled they don't
go to all phyla they specifically span i
think it's eight phyla
and we wanted to look more into those
specific phyla because these are the
ones that are really controlling the
fate of the carbon in this environment
so the next thing we want to do is
wanted to look well what are the host
capabilities because the virus can only
do so much for the hosts infecting right
you're driving a car now if your friend
has a mercedes and you have a little
scooter you're both driving a vehicle
but they have more influence they have
the capacity to go faster than you and
further than you because of what they're
in so this is like the virus in fact in
the host right it's limited based on the
capacity of the host
so we did is we wanted to look for the
various ways they could break down
carbon substrates
so i'm going to show you all of them but
i wanted to zoom in on one to orient you
and get you thinking about this we have
the phylum actinobacteria
on the y-axis we have the number of
genes within their genome and on the
x-axis it's the number of genes within
that substrate class so the first one's
cellulose so every circle there is a
bacterial genome that's an
actinobacteria and the entire up of it
has more genes to break down cellulose
okay
so higher counts means higher capacity
to break down plant biomass
higher counts across the whole field
means a high diversity to break down a
range of substrates
okay
so what we realized is that we took all
20 phyla and we looked at which ones the
viruses were infecting the viruses were
infecting the key carbon degraders so
the ones
with the largest amount of genes
involved in the highest diversity for
plant degradation so the viruses are
actually caring a lot about the carbon
and influencing the fate of this carbon
so this is just them doing it via
infecting the host by infecting the host
they can increase the host metabolism to
make more viruses they can light
somewhat dormant i don't like to use the
word dormant because while they're
integrated they're just not there they
are still doing
um
maintenance they're also encoding
different toxin genes to help the host
and protect the host from other
infection and keep it happy so there's a
lot viruses are doing
but if we look more at other ways the
viruses could be influenced metabolism
we start thinking about the different
ways in which they can control carbon
cycling so like i said before they lyse
the host this is releasing nutrients
into the environment that's a top down
control
if we
are also
expressing amgs this is augmenting the
host metabolism
we can make their metabolism more
efficient and make them out-compete
other populations as well
so we looked for these amgs and we found
a whole slew of amgs within our viral
populations connected to our hosts
so we think about this more because i'm
not done with this paper yet but we're
looking what is the fate of this carbon
okay so first idea is this kill the one
or hypothesis right the viruses are
shifting who they're infecting
we it's hard to see that here because
it's a 44 day incubation and there's not
really a time comparison so we really
can't see this but we know that viruses
are infecting the most abundant posts
that are involved in plant biomass
degradation so we do see that so this
could be maintaining the microbial
diversity and they're also killing all
these hosts creating diverse substrates
feeding other organisms
another thing you could be doing is the
viral shine where they're killing the
host
this necromass microbial necromancer all
the nutrients is becoming available but
then it's sticking and in these soils we
have phosphorus limitation and then we
have all these different pore sizes that
microbes can't fit in so maybe that the
viruses are killing these hosts these
nutrients are going in these small pore
sizes and it's inaccessible
to other microbes so it just keeps
carbon in the soil
and then this leads us to atonement so
by keeping that carbon in the soil it's
inaccessible it can persist for long
periods of time until maybe we till the
soil making it available for other
organisms there's a flood or there's a
storm that moves the soil or there's
small organisms like ultra small
bacteria that can make their way within
these pores and break down this carbon
okay
now that is stuff that i was currently
working on
about a year ago i got a grant
so this is what's called my ldrd and
this is to really push the field the
government gave me a grant
for something that's called high risk
high reward you're doing science that
has a high chance to fail
but if you were able to complete it
then it would be very valuable to the
community
so what i wanted to do was other ways we
could tackle increasing our detection of
microbes and viruses and getting better
resolution and again going at soils is a
great way because there's all of this
going on so how do we tease it apart and
really figure out what's going on
well we set up doing metagenomes
incubated with heavy water so i did over
a time series i took some soil i did
four different treatments over a time
series so the new component says i'm
adding time to really see how viruses
and microbes are changing
and how their host interactions are
changing
but we're also adding in our heavy water
to look at the active community over
time but i also added in a phosphorus
addition because i wanted to see
you know these these soils are limited
in phosphorus so if we're adding
phosphorus is this going to spur
infection
so that was the first part but that
alone doesn't just help us with our
detection so at the same time with these
soils i also took a virum which is a
viral targeted meducino and this is
actually what i spent my whole phd
optimizing
this is where you can take a sample for
here i'll take a soil sample
and you add a resuspension buffer to
help deserve the viruses from the
environment
you physically separate them and you run
through a filter so now you're looking
at the viral size fraction
and then you want to purify it so that
way it's not sticking anything and then
you extract the dna and concentrate so
now we're looking at not just the double
stranded dna that you get from a
metagenome but we've also
optimized it so we can get single and
double-stranded dna viruses from the
soil
and i've been recently working with jgis
with emily and simon rue here
in which we're trying to get stable eyes
to probing firearms the first of their
kind so this would be looking at active
viruses but in the virion stage in the
environment so there's no incorporations
okay so the benefits here is we get
increased resolution on our viruses and
we've shown this with previous work
you can also get increased resolution on
the ultra small microbes because they
make it to the fraction but we lose our
host information so it's good to have it
paired with the meta genome which is
what i've done
but we're still not done i wanted to
increase resolution of all of our
viruses correct
then we also added a meta transcriptome
rna viruses are super important
and a lot of mammals especially humans
and gorillas we see it seems to dominate
the literature like we only care about
rna viruses
but it's funny because for ecology when
you go into environmental systems like
soil or water they seem to be missed out
on we are only looking at
double-stranded dna viruses but there
have been recent studies looking at rna
viruses so i wanted to be able to
capture these also from this same sample
so we're going to get double-stranded
single-stranded dna viruses and also rna
viruses so this will capture all of our
rna viruses
we'll also be able to get gene
expression for a host and for our dna
viruses which would be great we're still
limited to the point where we have to
remove trna and rrna because they
swamped the signal so we do lose a
little bit of information there
finally something that i newly invented
and i'm working on is what i call the
edna metagenome there's been recent
studies that i think the first paper
that really pushed it into the eyes of
people was paul carini's 2016 paper
where he sampled some soils
and they found a lot of edna and that by
looking at the edna you're actually
seeing variances in the abundances of
your host so you need to be careful of
how much of the e-dna is actually just
relic dna lying around
and just to clarify relic dna ancient
dna edna which can be exogenous dna or
environmental dna it's all very similar
just dna that's free in the environment
that we're trying to understand
now i was working with this because
there's recent papers from wastewater
treatment facilities and aquatic
environments
showing that if you look at the e-dna
you can actually get increased detection
of viruses so i'm wanting to monitor the
viruses and get this increased detection
so we sampled edna from our soils too
and reconstructed that so just from this
one soil sample over this time series
with these four different treatments
we have a ton of sipmetic genomes we
have bulk metagenomes sip firearms bulk
firearms bulk metagenomes and e-dna ohms
that we're comparing and this is the
work that i'm actively doing right now
so i think in six months two years start
seeing some results coming from this and
looking at the whole soil virus sphere
of a sample and this is really looking
at the the vira ohm really of the soil
like all the different components of the
virus sphere
okay
so i'm gonna wrap up now but i wanted to
also talk about another component to
make sure that we're not missing out on
it
one of the issues with metagenomics
is that everyone everyone thinks
metaomic studies which is metagenomics
miniature experimental metaproteomics
and so on and meta metabolomics
that we're thinking we can just do it
and we're done
we need to make sure that we're taking
controls and trying to be quantitative
by adding in stable isotope probing we
can start looking activity you can also
add in bond cat which is bio-orthogonal
non-canonical amino acid tagging and
this can also get at activity
but another way too is we can try to use
microscopy to make sure we're
quantitative so what we're doing here is
we're taking our soil samples in which
we've taken these metagenomes and so on
and we're separating them and we're
trying to count the number of viral
particles now epifluorescence microscopy
doesn't do so well especially in soils
so we'll use transmission electron
microscopy but we've also taken a step
further and we've paired it with
nanosims which is nano scale secondary
ion mass spectroscopy
and the way this works is you take a
sample
you sputter it with a cesium beam
it destroys a sample but every time it
hits a sample it charges the sample and
the computer can read it and can
reconstruct an image
so
these figures you see have these
micrographed that are gray
those are tem images that we can see
viruses and you can see in the top right
here we have m13 phase which is a
filamentous phage that infects um
e coli
we also have down here we've been
working with lambda phage which is an
iconic um
sifoviridae shape and that also can
infect bacteria
now you can look over to the far right
we can start to do a nano symptoms and
nanotubes is great because it allows us
to not only quantitatively count the
viral particles but we can also see
the elemental composition
we can see if it's 13c enriched versus
12c rich we can see if there's carbon
there we can see if there's oxygen so we
can look at where the enrichment's going
we can also know what nutrients they're
taking from the house and what nutrients
they're putting in their environment so
this is something we're actively working
on as well to try to quantify phage from
the environment but also better
understand
their nutrients that they hold on to
okay so hopefully that wasn't too much
i'm sorry i was trying not to go too
fast but i want to leave time for
questions
i want to acknowledge everyone i worked
with i love universities
i never thought i'd work in a national
lab since coming to a national lab i see
so many benefits how you can really hone
in on your science and i can really
connect with universities so i can still
teach if i want to and give back to the
community so i really want to
acknowledge jennifer petridge and steve
blazowicz they've been excellent mentors
and helped me convert to a staff
scientist we have tons of funding we
have
ldrd for high risk and rewards research
to steve that i came in on i currently
have mine as well
we were funded by other organizations
for some of the studies we also have our
large sfa which is a science focus area
that's ongoing for the next couple years
where we're really trying to understand
how precipitation affects microbial
populations in soils specifically in
california we will have absolutely no
rainfall really from about may
to october sometimes
and so we have all of these organisms
including the grass that just go dormant
and then from about november
to april may we'll start to get rainfall
and these organisms will come alive and
this really controls the carbon output
from the car from the sorry the carbon
output from the soil so we're trying to
understand how moisture really dictates
these communities in their trades
and then lastly i want to do a land
acknowledgement we're only here because
the people that took care of this land
so i'm super appreciative of being able
to sample these lands and work on these